bonjour aujourd'hui l'honorable leona
aglukkaq ministre de l'environnement
ministre de l'agencé canadienne de
développement économique du nord et
ministre du conseil de l'arctique a fait
la déclaration suivante au sujet de
l'intention de la ville de montréal de
déverser 8 milliards de litres d'eaux
usées dans le fleuve c'est l'eau le
fleuve scellera est l'un des cours d'eau
les plus importants du canada hébergeant
plusieurs espèces de baleines et de
poissons et alimentant des milliers de
canadiens en eau potable
en outre de nombreux québécois
l'utilisent a dit fehr et créative
la proposition de la ville de montréal
de déverser des milliards de litres
d'eaux usées non traitées dans cet
important cours d'eau est très
préoccupante comme l'on dit publiquement
de nombreux citoyens
l'article 36 points 3 de la loi des
pêches stipule qu'il est interdit
d'immerger ou de rejeter une substance
nocive dans des eaux où vivent des
poissons à la demande de la ministre
environnement canada a contacté la ville
de montréal afin d'obtenir plus
d'informations sur ces plans et évaluer
les conséquences environnementales
possible la ministre ajoute j'ai demandé
à environnement canada d'explorer des
options a fait d'empêcher ce rejet
pendant que nous recueillons plus
d'information sur l'impact
environnemental des plans de la ville de
montréal
la mineuse demande donc au maire denis
coderre de suspendre ses plans tant qu
une évaluation appropriée n'aura pas été
effectuée nous allons continuer à
surveiller et à évaluer cette situation
de près afin d'assurer la protection des
canadiens des québécois et de leur
environnement